welcome welcome to Queen's University
agreement 25 conference and thank you
Emma for those important words and for
representing the students the 25
000 students of Queens at this historic
Gathering because it's so appropriate
since uh this is truly about the futures
of the young people of Northern Ireland
who are the true subjects of our
gathering today
thank you Vice Chancellor Greer for your
Visionary leadership of the University
and a special thank you to George
Mitchell an esteemed former Chancellor
of Queens as well as a colleague and
friend
America and Northern Ireland were well
served throughout the long Public
Service of George Mitchell and the long
road to peace under his capable
leadership
thank you
foreign he rightfully earned not only
the respect
but also the trust of participants on
all sides
I was pleased to work with him at the
state department and I am so delighted
he will share his reflections with you
today
it is also an honor to be joined by so
many
important participants of the Good
Friday agreement and its aftermath who
you will hear from over the next three
days the Lord mayor of Belfast Tony
Blair Bertie Ahern Bill Clinton all of
whom will be speaking the conference
co-chairs Ryan Feeney and Professor
Richard English as well as distinguished
faculty of this University students
alumni and guests from around the world
on the 25th anniversary of the Good
Friday agreement I think we can all
agree to celebrate a significant
Milestone with both a sense of
accomplishment but also of Hope and
determination that the next 25 years
will bring more fully the peace
prosperity and safety the agreement
promised
now there can be no doubt that people in
Northern Ireland today
enjoy Safety and Security
much more than those who had lived
through the previous decades that they
could have only dreamed of
and the longevity of the Good Friday
agreement
remains a true Triumph of diplomacy and
a testament to democracies power to
transcend divisions and deliver peace
but it is primarily a testament
to a lot of tough determined everyday
people who refused to go back to the
days of division and violence
this first day of the conference is
titled reflect
as we hear from The Architects of the
1998 Belfast agreement
tomorrow is titled renew
as we discuss what should be done to
fulfill the promise of the agreement
and day three is to reimagine the
economic prospects for Northern Ireland
especially in light of the Windsor
agreement framework
so you will hear from the architect soon
but first let me just make a few points
about what we are celebrating and about
the work that remains
I think all of us know how difficult it
was to secure the Good Friday agreement
how much work and sacrifice it took on
all sides to bring about peace and how
much effort has gone into
implementing its tenets and building a
new government in Northern Ireland
the credit for peace ultimately
goes to the brave people of Northern
Ireland
who took risks for peace
I well remember bills in my first trip
here in 1995. the first time a sitting
United States President visited Northern
Ireland
and after the Christmas tree lighting
ceremony in front of Belfast City Hall
in the midst of that enormous crowd
where so many of the people gathered
were holding the hands of their children
or holding smaller children on their
shoulders we gathered right here in
Whitlow Hall
Catholic leadership stood on one side of
the room
Protestants stood on the other
it was not easy for them to reach across
that literal physical divide
it took years of building trust and it
took courage
bill and I moved back and forth between
them meeting and talking with them
we understood then
that making peace and making peace
endure
would require patience
and follow through and would take time
I remember also on a visit in 2009 when
I was Secretary of State talking with
Martin McGinnis and Peter Robinson as
they worked through thorny challenges of
governing together
that took courage to
and of course there wouldn't be a good
Friday agreement to celebrate today if
it were not for the women of Northern
Ireland
I will remember starting in 1995 meeting
with Protestant and Catholic women
mothers and daughters sisters aunts
friends who may have attended different
churches on Sunday
but seven days a week prayed
that their husbands and their sons
their friends
would come back and forth from work from
shopping
peacefully
prayed for a better future for their
children and grandchildren
women like the late momoam Inez
McCormick Pat Hume determined
Unstoppable forces for peace
and Joyce mccartan who brought together
Protestant and Catholic women
in a safe house where they realized they
all wanted the same things good jobs
good schools
peaceful secure neighborhoods
streets you could walk safely down
security and prosperity you could count
on to build a life
and human rights
women like brona Hines Monica McWilliams
J Morris and pearl Sagar who formed
their own political party in 1996 in
order to participate in the formal peace
negotiations
a quarter Century of Bloodshed and
strife
and Millennia of embedded sexism had
discouraged most women from being in
politics from being in the arena
but not them
one of the goals of this conference is
to recognize the role that women played
and are playing in peace building
and we're also here to amplify the
voices of the next generation of leaders
and to create a dialogue to address the
major issues impacting society today so
we can keep building on the current
piece over the next 25 years
because while the Good Friday agreement
is an enormous achievement
we know that peace prosperity and
progress that so many have worked
tirelessly to achieve remains incomplete
the work of integration and housing and
schools is far from finished
neighborhoods remain divided poverty and
unemployment persist
the difficulties of the past
continue to threaten the present
you know we are at a standstill with the
Northern Ireland assembly no longer
functioning
but the Windsor agreement provides a
path forward not just for convening but
for positioning Northern Ireland as an
economic hub for global trade and
investment through privileged access to
the UK and all of its trading partners
as well as the EU
now there have been many moments in
Northern Ireland's peace Journey
where progress seemed difficult when
every route forward looked blocked
there seemed nowhere to go
but you have always found a way through
and I believe you will again because the
stakes for the people of Northern
Ireland are so high
you stand as an example to the world of
how even the staunchest adversaries
can overcome differences to work
together for the common and greater good
so I encourage everyone now to move
forward with the same Spirit of
Unstoppable grit and resolve
that brought the peace 25 years ago
your friends in the United States will
be behind you all the way as you work
toward peace prosperity and stability
that lasts
so that is what we are here to discuss
over the next three days
this forum will provide a chance for
leaders who created the agreement and
those working to extend it and realize
its full promise to share their
experiences and Visions for the future
what I find so remarkable about being
here at Queens is that many of the 25
000 students were born after the Good
Friday agreement was signed
yet they studied together in McClay
Library they play sports and join clubs
together they have those long deep
conversations you have at University
late Into the Night
the ordinary activities of students all
over the world
but when considered in the context of
Northern Ireland's history
the idea of young people from all
communities unionists and nationalists
Republicans and loyalists
becoming one another's friends
classmates and mentors it's clear
there's nothing ordinary at all about
what has been built here at Queens
and what an example and model it sets
for not just Northern Ireland but the
rest of us
because Queen's mission is
transformation of knowledge and learning
of individuals and societies of leaving
its mark on history and the world
consider the motto of both the
university and Belfast
taking from Psalms 116.
what shall we give in return for so much
the answer has been clear from the
beginning
as much as we can
and one of the driving reasons to resume
the government to get about the business
of governing
is that right now 33 percent of school
leavers in Northern Ireland leave to
seek their Futures elsewhere taking with
them their skills their education their
Ambitions their dreams
the ongoing struggle to finish the Good
Friday agreement and claim its full
promise
is a reminder of one of the things I try
to remember in my life when I've been
really high or really low
there are no final victories or defeats
in life
the most important thing is to fight the
right fight and to keep doing it the
best you can for as long as you can
I want to leave you with one final story
three years after my first visit to
Northern Ireland I helped organize the
vital voices Conference of women in
Belfast at the new International
Conference Center
women who were coming together in public
to find solutions to the conflict to
contribute to a lasting peace
as I spoke from the podium I looked up
and I saw the leaders of shin Fein
sitting in the front row of the balcony
and right behind them I saw the leaders
of the dup
at the time the parties and the
individuals were not speaking to each
other
but the fact that they were both in the
same room
at a Women's Conference for peace
exemplified their openness to listening
to compromising two agreeing on a better
future for the place they all cherished
we cannot take the progress we've seen
for granted
it's what a 15 year old boy named Mark
Lennox from Glenn Gormley High School
wrote in a letter to my husband in 1995.
he wrote If Northern Ireland is to have
a future then we must all work hard for
peace and make a real effort we will
have to change our ideas and work for
change
that is the choice the people of
Northern Ireland made in 1998
and it is the choice I hope you will
continue to make
this 25th anniversary is the opportunity
so many generations have worked toward
and waited for
give the people of Northern Ireland the
future they deserve especially for their
children and grandchildren so let's get
to work to see that men and women join
together
to make the world as well as Northern
Ireland better for the next 25 years and
25 after that Godspeed
thank you
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
thank you for being here to witness this
historic anniversary
may it be the first of May
thank you for your very warm reception
it's a great honor and a pleasure for me
and my wife Heather to be here with you
today
and expect especially grateful
to cancel around the vice Chancellor
around his staff here at Queen's
University
they've worked long and hard to organize
this week's events
they've welcomed all of us
citizens of Northern Ireland teachers
school children media politicians follow
us with extraordinary warmth and
Hospitality thank you Hillary and Ian
for what you've done in organized in
this conference
25 years ago the people of Northern
Ireland and their leaders changed the
course of history
it was a day when history opened itself
to Hope
the people of Northern Ireland supported
worked for and established a democratic
peaceful process
as their preferred form of governments
they overwhelmingly rejected political
violence as a way to resolve their
differences
if history teaches us anything
it is that history itself is never
finished
on the evening the agreement was reached
I commended the men and women who wrote
and signed it
but I also said that it would take other
leaders in the future
to safeguard and extend their work
and so it has
I am here
with many others
sound that Bell
one more time
life is change
for every human being for every family
for every government for every society
all human beings every single one of us
is fallible
as are all human organizations and
institutions
and in human Affairs the answer to every
problem contained within the seeds of a
new problem
today a quarter Century after the
agreement
people of Northern Ireland continue to
wrestle with their palace their
differences their disagreements
this of course is only natural and they
will continue to do so no matter how
successful their political leaders are
the answer is not perfection
or permanence it is now as it was then
for the current and Future Leaders of
Northern Ireland to act with courage and
vision
as their predecessors did 25 years ago
to find workable answers
to the Daily problems of the present
to preserve peace
to leave to the Next Generation peace
freedom opportunity
and the hope of a better future for
their children
one of the strengths of democracy
is the right of all citizens to publicly
disagree with and to criticize their
government officials
and their policies
but all values when carried to extremes
can become vices
so if there's one bit of unsolicited
advice I'd like to give to the people of
Northern Ireland
it's this
don't always be so hard on yourselves
at the same time never ever give up on
the belief
that we all can do better
and feedback
the future becomes the present in
heartbeat
six years ago I made one of my many
visitors to Northern Ireland
the United Kingdom was wrestling with
brexit in the United States we had just
elected president Trump
while I was here I was asked several
times
essentially the same question
can you comment on how terrible and
upsetting politics are here in Northern
Ireland
so much anger so much disagreement so
much distrust
in reply I said well I can't speak to
the UK but I just come from the United
States and I don't think any American is
in a position to lecture others on their
disagreements
thank you
I spoke those words six years ago and
they were even more relevant today
I do acknowledge
with a nod to the great sense of humor
that often accompanies it that people in
Northern Ireland are are equipped to
take offense
I was made aware of this quite
dramatically in June of 1996 on the very
first day of the all-party talks in a
large conference room filled with
delegates from the two governments and
10 political parties David Irvine in a
loud voice shouted across the room to me
Senator he said if you are committing to
be of any use to us there is one thing
you must understand what is it I ask
there's a smile on his face he replied
we in Northern Ireland will drive 100
miles out of our way to receive an
insult
like you I laughed thinking it was a
joke
but as I looked around the room they
weren't laughing
they were all nodding in agreement
over the next few years I've witnessed
firsthand
the unique skill of Northern Ireland
politicians in the art of insulting
their opponents but a wise person
can always be superior to the insults he
or she receives wisdom and courage and
Grace
and even stubborn desire
can help to sow peace and root it down
deep in the soil
where it can once again grow
so I say now to the current
and Future Leaders of Northern Ireland
there is much in your history and in
your politics that divides you
but there also is much that can bring
you together that can inspire you to
continue what your predecessors began a
quarter century ago
it is not a sign of weakness to resolve
your differences by Democratic and
peaceful means to the contrary it is a
sign of strength and of wisdom thank you
and it clearly reflects the will
of the overwhelming majority of the
people of Northern Ireland yes they
often disagree sometimes very strongly
yes they may take offense quickly
but it is unmistakably clear that the
people of Northern Ireland do not want
to return to violence not now and not
out
thank you
I know that each of your parties like
all political parties in the world
have some of what I call the 100
presenters they want everything their
way all the time
to them any compromise is a sign of
weakness but I say to you that reasoned
principle compromise is essential
especially in divided societies and it
reflects a belief in democratic values
that we all understand
there is great depth in recognizing
that the only way to help us emerge from
the role of conflict
is that we must learn to understand one
another
we don't need to love one another
we don't even need to like one another
although we hope we could
but we must learn to understand one
another and to be able to say yes to one
another
especially when the quicker and easier
answer is no because like it or not we
are all in this together
facing the reality of the future rather
than clinging to the midst of the past
take strength and courage and vision
those we honor Today Show those
qualities a quarter of a century ago
they will be forever remembered
and others
will be remembered as well
one grim
but tangible memory
is in these statistics
according to the Northern Ireland Police
Service and the Northern Ireland
statistics agency
from a side of the troubles until 1998
over 3
500 people were killed and an estimated
000 were injured in sectarian violence
in the 25 years since the agreement was
reached there have been about
164 security related deaths
but don't think of these Justice numbers
because they are not
think of them as mothers and fathers
sons and daughters
whose lives were cut short
or permanently appeared
still to this day their lives echo down
through the years
and so I asked each and every person in
this Hall
stand and honor all of these lives and
everyone was an individual human being
all of these lives with a moment of
silence please stand
thank you
please be seated
there have been many architects
in the house of peace
it is impossible to name them all
they of course include president and
secretary Clinton
I'm very grateful to President Clinton
for appointing me to serve as his
representative in Northern Ireland
and for his unswerving support for me
and to the people of Northern Ireland
during the long years of failure that
followed
until we got in agreement
Prime Ministers Blair and a Hearn were
absolutely indispensable
to the process
as were other leaders of the UK and
Irish governments
many of their predecessors helped to lay
the foundations for peace
they include Albert Reynolds and John
Bruton in Ireland
and John Major in the United Kingdom
major and Bruton made the crucial
decisions to establish the all-party
talks and to invite the independent
chairman
to have that process
I shared that role with two
extraordinary men
the late Harry Potter the former prime
minister of Finland
and General John deschastolay the former
head of the Canadian Defense Forces
each of us was well served by small but
variable status for me they included
Martha Pope David pozerski and Kelly
Curry
both governments were represented by a
succession of very able ministers and
officials they included from the UK Lord
Patrick Mayhew Sir Michael ankom Momo
Lord Paul Murphy Jonathan Powell and
Bill Jeffries
from Ireland dick spring David Andrews
Sean o'guin Liz O'Donnell David Cooney
Tim O'Connor and David Donahue
special recognition must of course go
to the leaders of the major Northern
Ireland parties
John Dew led the Social Democratic and
labor party
and David Trimble led the Ulster
unionist party
without John you
there would not have been a peace
process
thank you
without David Trimble there would not
have been a peace agreement
they were justly awarded the Nobel Peace
Prize
Lord Trimble later served as the first
minister of the Northern Ireland
government in the uup he was greatly
aided by several key officials among
them Lord reg MP Lord Lord John Taylor
Lord Ken McGinnis and Sir Jeffrey
Donaldson in the sdlp
John Hume received strong support from
several talented leaders including
Seamus Mallon brilliant orator and
negotiator who later became Deputy first
Minister and Mark Durkin brid Rogers and
Sean Farrell
Jerry Adams and the late Martin McGinnis
LED Shinn Fein into and through the
entire process they were assisted by
Jerry Kelly Barbara de bruyne and Alex
Masky who is now the speaker of the
Northern Ireland assembly they were all
and always strong and effective
advocates for their cause
later again to served for several years
as Deputy first minister
Dr Ian Paisley was a long time and
strong leader of the democratic unionist
Parliament the dup withdrew from the
talks and opposed the agreement but they
later re-entered the process at crucial
talks in Saint Andrews and thereafter
participated actively in governors Dr
Paisley served for several years as
first Minister where he and Martin
McGinnis achieved some celebrity as the
chuckles Brothers
Paisley was succeeded as dup leader and
first Minister by Peter Robinson who had
been a very effective negotiator while
the dup was in the talks they Paisley
Robinson were ably assisted in the Talks
by Nigel Dodds and Ian Paisley Jr
the alliance party was led by Dr John
alderdice he and his colleagues were
very effective in the talks and he later
served with distinction as the first
Speaker of the Northern Ireland assembly
and his colleague Eileen Bell also later
served in that same role
the Northern Ireland women's party led
by Monica McWilliams and pearl saber
played a vital role as indeed did all of
the women in all of the coalitions that
stitched the threads of Peace together
[Applause]
the loyalist parties were small in
number but they played a very large role
in the negotiations their leaders were
David Irvine and Gary McMichael both
were outstanding and Powerful advocates
for peace they were assisted by other
articulate leaders like Billy Hutchinson
and Don Purvis
the labor party was effectively led by
Maliki Curran
with the rest with the perspective of a
quarter century the strength of these
leaders and the people they represented
has become clear
their places in history have been
assured
I now know them all as friends
the only thing that gives me pause
about reading this long list of honorees
is that in the dust of my memory
I likely have inadvertently left out of
some who should have been included
and if so I sincerely and profoundly
apologize
so I'd like to now ask you to stand
again to applaud these courageous men
and women who brought peace to Northern
Ireland with a sound that will ring out
for years to come
thank you
the course of every true idea ends up
eventually
in the audience
peace is a true idea
it must belong to us all
it can't be in some ways more difficult
than War
but it must be pursued
it is our past
the task of our children and of their
children
to ensure this peace
so that history
continues to open itself to Hope
speaking of children
in October of 1997
my wife Heather gave birth to our son
Andrew
by then I have been involved in Northern
Ireland for nearly three years
the old party talks have been going on
for a year and a half
and there had been no meaningful
progress
actually no progress of any kind
in many respects the talks were about
reciting and repeating history rather
than changing it
the ceasefires were routinely violated
some parties entered late some left
early
the anger the hostility the obstacles
all seem endless
over and over again I was asked
Senator since you have failed to get an
agreement when are you leaving Northern
Ireland to go home
earlier that year after an especially
difficult period
Heather and I briefly discussed that
question
I told her I wanted to stay and she
agreed
so I returned and as I had always done I
answered that same question day after
day saying that while it was true that
we hadn't gotten an agreement
I still felt it worthwhile to continue
the effort
try to end the violence
but then
our son Andrew was born
and as every parent knows my life
and my responsibilities would change
irreversible
I flew home for his birth
and I also made plans to travel to
Washington
to meet with President Clinton's
National Security advisor my intention
was to tell him
that I was for the first time
seriously considering leaving Northern
Ireland
to ask for his reaction and advice
to request a meeting with the president
to discuss the matter
I have continued my close relationship
with President Clinton
has he and Mrs Clinton maintained a deep
concern and an intense personal interest
in Northern Ireland
my wife Heather had to remain in a
hospital with Andrew
for a few days
so it was there
that we had a long and summer talk about
the future
I had asked and was told that on the day
of Andrew's birth
61 children were born in Northern
Ireland
we talked about
but Andrew's life life is like
and about their lives
of the 61 children from Northern Ireland
then I told Heather
that I was going to Washington
and why
her reaction was immediate and strong
she said you have to go back until it
ends one way or the other
if you leave now when the fighting
resumes
and lots of people died
to forgive yourself
go back
give it one last try
I'll take good care of Andrew
you think about those 61 children from
Northern Ireland
so I
thank you
so I canceled the trip to Washington and
returned to Northern Ireland
and when I got back to Belfast I felt
like I was coming home
but coming home doesn't always mean
returning to safety unfortunately the
situation continued
to carry around just before Christmas of
1997 I met with the party leaders try to
get them to agree on a statement of the
major issues to be resolved mind you
this is not trying to get agreement on
the answer with any questions it was
after a year and a half of discussion
just to get them to agree on the wording
of the issues that were to be resolved
at first the meeting was amicable and
positive
that suddenly the move turned intensely
negative
the old resentments Returns the insults
resumed
and the meeting broke up in anger and
acrimony
for the first time I felt a sense of
defeat
then it quickly got even worse a few
days later just after Christmas
a prominent loyalist paramilitary leader
was killed while in prison that touched
off a round of retaliatory violence that
threatened to end the talks
the plunge Northern Ireland backed into
the troubles
the next series of meetings some in
London in January and in Dublin in
February were not in any sense
negotiations
the contrary they became hopeless for
anger for hostility and the desire for
Revenge as each side blamed the other
for the escalating violence two parties
were suspended from their dogs
as we left Dublin the mood was negative
and the Outlook leak
so much effort seemed to be going down
the drain of History
on a flight back to the U.S my sense of
defeat and despair people
and then I recalled Heather's words one
last try
took out a pad of paper and I wrote down
the draft of a plan
the final intensive effort with an early
unbreakable deadline
I talked with my two colleagues
prime minister Hall Korean General the
Shasta Lane they were in full agreement
when it returned to Belfast in March we
headed into discussions with the two
governments and the eight political
parties still in the darks to get an
agreement on an early unbreakable
deadline for an end of the talks one way
or the other
that discussion was long and difficult
finally in late March we got agreement
on two weeks of final negotiations and
crucially an unbreakable deadline
my sense of Despair gave way to a sense
of hope
for one important reason
we the independent chairman had no
authority to impose a deadline
we could propose it as we had
but it required the approval of both
governments under each party
the fact that everybody's still in the
talks agreed to the deadline meant to me
that they were sincere in wanting and
end to the conflict despite their deep
differences and then nearly two years of
unproductive haggling they'd just been
through
they still face very difficult issues
issues on which they had strongly
complete
but they did not want to return to the
violence of the past and the only way to
do that was to reach energy
there was another reason for my hopes
personal to me and much less serious
I've been involved in Northern Ireland
for more than three years but I still
had a hard time understanding some of
what was being said in the negotiations
I've spent 50 years of the United States
Senate the last six as the Senate's
leader the debates were vigorous but
only one speaker at a time
here especially in the early years
there was disorder delegates from 10
political parties hurled insults back
and forth shouted at and insulted each
other and some regularly and loudly
stormed out in protest I learned that
the dramatic workout is a major feature
and the only thing that reminded me of
the Senate was that some people spoke
often and had very great plans
it took a long time to establish an
orderly process along the way I made
many mistakes
one of them was at the beginning of the
talks
and it was in a naive and misguided
effort on my partner to be helpful as a
politician myself I knew that all of
them politicians liked to talk
and none of them like to listen so I
foolishly said to them if no one else
would listen to you I will be here you
will be heard
how I regret that
hold on
it wasn't weeks it wasn't months it was
years that I listened to the same people
saying the same thing over and over and
over again and many of them talk very
fast with accents that I couldn't quite
figure out
so to improve my understanding
I held many many hundreds of informal
meetings in my office and theirs where I
said little and listened as much as
possible
listening
really listening to someone else speak
is hard especially when it goes on for
years but it's also a sign of respect
and I respected them for what they were
trying to do
by a fortunate coincidence this effort
began to pay off
in the lengthy discussions to establish
the deadline so as we began the last two
intensive weeks I was encouraged by the
fact that finally I could understand
everything that was being said
more importantly the long period of
listening greatly helped me in the
search for common ground
we set a deadline of midnight Thursday
April 9th we didn't meet that deadline
and we also failed to meet the targets
we had set for each of the 14 days of
the final effort
my memory of those two weeks is a blur
of constant activity has two governments
eight political parties and the
independent chairman sought a written
agreement on which all could agree on
three complex and related relationships
within Northern Ireland
between Northern Ireland and Ireland
and between Ireland and the United
Kingdom
my admiration grew for the men and women
who struggled to find Common Grounds
against the history of distrust
disagreement and violence to the limits
of the physical capacity
and under enormous political pressure
on the last week Prime Ministers Blair
and Ahern came to Belfast and assumed
active and highly effective leadership
in the talks on the last night President
Clinton stayed up all night in the white
house talking to the prime ministers and
to the party leaders
by the morning or Friday April 10th we
had assembled the product of all of
these efforts into a single document
two years earlier at the beginning of
the talks I had told the delegates that
if there was ever to be an agreement
it had to be theirs no acceptable
agreement
could be imposed from above
or from outside
as we distributed the final document to
them that morning I reminded them of
that statement orally and in writing I
said to them virtually every word in
this document has been spoken or written
by someone from Northern Ireland this is
your agreement
it is of necessity a compromise it does
not resolve every issue there is much in
it you will not like there is much you
will like
this is Ian
how you must decide
that I asked each of them please
say yes
each of the parties then went into
caucus through the day they debated the
future of their Homeland
of their constituents of their failures
their questions and concerns were many
and variants the prime ministers tried
to answer their questions
to reassure them
to encourage their approval
by the afternoon the final call started
coming in at first the trickled than a
rush
and then there was a law as I waited for
the last call
shortly before five
David Trimble called
I will never forget his words
we're ready to do the business
Party leaders and the government
officials gathered in the large
conference room
already crowded with reporters
television Crews and staff many of us
I had suggested an immediate vote
to be followed by a discussion
nobody objected or disagreed
and the excitement at the moment they
just started talking and they went on
until everyone had their say I realized
that my suggestion was wishful thinking
and the discussion continued
they were ready to vote
that was fitting because it was their
agreement
it still is
and it always will be theirs and yours
so that history continues to open itself
to Hope
in the future politicians will tell it
one way
the publics will tell it another
and the history books still yet another
but it's likely that none of us will say
it in precisely the way that our
grandchildren and their children will
understand
what has led us here has not been
perfect
what surrounds us now
is not guaranteed
and what would lead us on is the ability
to recognize the faults of the past
and the dreams of the future
the agreement reached in 1998 did not
resolve all of the outstanding issues it
was a political compromise the best that
could be achieved at that time
in the years since the agreement there
have been many Chronicles describing
those momentous events many individuals
have been lighted for their efforts and
appropriately so
I believe it clear that the greatest
heroes were the people of Northern
Ireland and their political leaders in
the most difficult and dangerous of
circumstances those leaders acted with
coverage
this vision
and determination
at one time or another all were
criticized or rebuked
some lost their public offices
some of their political parties suffer
huge declines
but most remarkable feats
often suffer setbacks I believe the
verdict of History will be immensely
favorable
to the people of Ireland north and south
and their leaders peace may come
dropping slowly but when it settles it
confirms the humanity in all of us
triggered by this anniversary there has
been much discussion recently about the
agreement
of course everyone is entitled to indeed
encouraged to express their views
some in and out of Northern Ireland have
criticized the agreement because it did
not solve every problem and because
there continued to be in Northern
Ireland some failure disappointment
dispute
disagreement
but I respectfully disagree with these
criticals I believe the statistics on
deaths and injuries I cited earlier are
by by themselves a powerful response to
such comics those who Advocate such cues
are in effect holding Northern Ireland
to an impossibly high standard that no
other Society could be or does mean
what Society doesn't have violence what
Society doesn't have some criminals
including some masquerading as Patriots
what Society doesn't have disagreements
dispute some disarray and I say as a
visitor and a friend Northern Ireland is
a good place the people are good people
they're energetic they're hard working
they're hospitable they're trying to do
what's right even as they disagree on
its definition
they want peace
going forward let's accentuate the
positive in Northern Ireland we'd not we
need not eliminate the negative let's
just keep it in perspective
my final words today are intensely
personal
as many of you know three years ago I
was hospitalized with acute leukemia
to this day I continue to receive
treatment as a result my ability to
function has been severely diminished
this is the first time in three years
that I've attended and talked at a major
public event
but Heather and I
came here today
because we want to say personally and
directly to you
and throw you to all the people of
Northern Ireland
from the bottom of our hearts we thank
you for your warmth your hospitality
your generosity
we love Northern Ireland
people in the place
and a very large part of our hearts
and of our emotions
will forever be with you
in approving the agreement
by overwhelming majorities
in a free and democratic election
the people of Northern Ireland and the
violin showed others
the possibility of Hope
within the word impossible
is embedded the part the positive word
possible
when you approve the agreement
you were also talking to Israelis and
Palestinians to Colombians to Africans
to Asians to Americans
in fact you were talking to the world
this is an agreement for peace
and for the future
not just here
but everywhere
we are living in fractured times we need
you
we need your ongoing patience stamina
and perseverance we need people who
believe who know
that the possible does exist within the
impossible
don't let it slip away
may God grant you the opportunity and
prosperity and everlasting peace you
deserve
thank you Northern Ireland from the
bottom of my heart thank you Northern
Ireland
foreign
thank you
well follow that
Senator Mitchell thank you so much for
such a memorable address and for sharing
your wisdom with us I think we also
probably just got some sense of your
charm and your humor that must have
helped a lot in those long long
negotiations
um I'm sure you'd all agree that it has
been an absolute privilege to be in the
audience this morning and to hear the
different perspectives from our speakers
but I think I speak for everybody here
when I say I truly honored who they are
that Senator Mitchell has been with us
today
Senator we will long remember and be
grateful for your skill your patience
your determination and your devotion can
we have another round of applause
[Applause]
foreign
listening to this morning speakers many
of you have been thinking back about the
last 24 years and just how much has
changed in Northern Ireland so now we've
got the chance to hear some Reflections
from our first panel it's called
Building Bridges the two governments and
in a few moments I'll invite the
panelists to join us on stage they're
led by our chair Professor Mary mcleese
the former president of Ireland and the
professor is joined by Paul Murphy Lord
Murphy former Secretary of State for
Northern Ireland by Tim O'Connor a
former Secretary General to the
president of Ireland lizard Donald a
former minister of state and
representative of the Irish government
in those negotiations and Jonathan
Powell the lead British negotiator on
the agreement so please join me in
welcoming them all on stage
foreign